yes there are things where characters
enter the movie just to do one thing to
make everything more convenient and like
you'll see there's one scene where well
you know Mark Wahlberg and Denzel
Washington are at odds and then a
henchman wakes up from being dead for
one second just just shoot out a window
and cause a distraction and then
anodized right oh it's like it's not
even like that's that could have been
worth it if one of them killed that
happen but no he just comes back shoot
something and I'd you literally stands
up fires the gun and impart whoever
drives off and then he's just Falls like
it's like that at that point I became a
Friday the 13th movies like this guy
just showed up to add to the body count
and help our character for a second leg
yeah my name is ryan right and i'm
cheering welcome the reasons to see we
give you reasons to see and not to see
two guns let's make it ring reason to
see number one mark wahlberg miss movie
okay right Denzel Washington so mark
wahlberg Mark Wahlberg is the best thing
in this [ __ ] movie there's not a lot
of best things in this movie but he is
the best thing in this movie he is he's
like the wacky character you know
they're both kind of the guy who doesn't
play by the book but but he's the guy
who doesn't play by the book more he
doesn't understand people and he's very
expression it yeah and he does it in the
Mark Wahlberg fashion is but that
attitude yes he's like tough but
sensitive he had tough but charming yeah
is easy a witty and stuff yeah he's
funny he's fine he's like a Martin Riggs
of this movie except he's a supporting
character reason to see number two mark
wahlberg and Denzel Washington finally
together the best moments in this movie
when these two were on screen together
which it should be reason to see number
one it should be but it doesn't happen
quite enough yeah get back thanks
actly there should have been more of
this in the movie whatever mark wahlberg
and Denzel Washington are sharing the
screen together playing off each other
at odds with one another that's when the
movie is the most fun and it's when
everything works them yeah it's the it's
one of the few times where the script
makes sense and they elevated really bad
dialogue it's fantastic it out they they
work together they manage to still bring
good performances out of it only mark
wahlberg can pull a fart joke in a
serious movie reason to see number three
Denzel Washington apparently this like
55 years it's about so 50 year old
actors now be badasses Denzel Washington
doesn't age ever know he does hit it
right rainy day he just stopped it so
easily just gonna stay with some
ambiguous age forever he's good at these
action movie roles he's really good at
them and he's a he's a badass again d
he's always a badass he's got the best
walk ever and he's like walking on the
cloud or sounds like a swagger yeah he's
got swag man dude Denzel [ __ ] dude suck
your dick reason to see number four the
score dude this movie has some of the
coolest [ __ ] music ever this movie
does not deserve the music again sir but
it's some really cool music it's like a
Western II kind of rock and roll it
seems like the music supervisor thought
they were making a different movie yeah
it's got that like kind of slowly short
a groovy a heist movie kind of western
emusic you know yeah yeah whether or not
it makes sense it's all groovy it only
fits when Denzel Washington and we're at
Wahlburgers just walk exactly the only
time one close to anything moving reason
to see number 5 cinematography I like
the cinematography this a lot it's kind
of like it reminds me of a lot of like
watching a Steven Soderbergh picture in
a lot of ways it's got kind of that you
know like the long shots and everything
like that and the wide angles and just
the way it looks kind of looks like a
soderbergh movie sometimes not all the
time but stan getz cinematography yeah
it looks good you know it's a it's
captured well enough yeah
frame good and I mean the way they shoot
some of those you know more action
especially when when people are getting
hit directly with things or cards are
crashing like that that's the whole
looks great yeah there was some really
cool cinematography it's just a movie
didn't make much sense reason to see
number six so the action mother [ __ ]
that was unnecessary up really that was
an assassin it's a strong sort of thing
I don't think anyone was was was like
you know gauteng yeah you some of the
action and I don't this movie's not
filled with action like you might
believe it is it is mainly um a lot of
weird stuff but the action at times is
pretty sweet yeah well and the thing I
noticed about this movie is there are a
number of times where things happen and
and I don't do this like you know on
purpose it's just like someone will get
hit you know like they hit mark wahlberg
with a bat at one point I was like oh uh
like what actually made a physical noise
during a lot of these actions these
especially on hits you knows like cars
crash into each other or the way they
shoot you know some pants that shot yes
something I admired about it is that it
felt violent and it somehow fits for
this movie but when you watch the
trailer you're not expecting a violent
movie mark wahlberg and ends up pull it
off incredibly and do gosh Riggs and
Murtagh you are back reasons not to see
that damn trailer spoils too much oh so
um for the love of God don't watch the
trailer and they're interested in this
movie trailer is basically based off the
last 40 minutes of this film man this is
like a two-hour flick or something like
that here's here's the problem i feel
like the trailer was edited in a very
short-sighted way it's like I know you
gotta pitch what's interesting about
your movie and get butts in seats but
you have to think past opening weekend
because the problem is the trailer gives
away pretty much all of the movies big
surprises you can't make a trailer that
gives away all the big surprises and
then have a movie that doesn't play
itself like you know those surprises so
it's like the movie comes undone when
you know that because then you're just
waiting for those information
that's the key out yeah you know um when
you watch this trailer you think by act
2 it's going to be like oh did you know
that sergeant Murtagh is sergeant
Murtagh and you know with that officer
Riggs is officer Riggs and easy think
they team up and they're gonna work
together to take down whatever bad guys
you're trying to take down and that
doesn't happen to like 80 minutes into
the film reason not to see number two
weird tone the tone is the strangest
thing about this [ __ ] thing yeah a
little bit how we both felt we set it to
each other in the theater yeah there's
like the same exact thought yeah was it
felt like every scene like every 10
minutes or so yeah was being written by
another right I'd like someone else was
a replaced every single 10 minutes or
something do you know what I want to be
like I've never I've never been in a
movie or at least I can't recall one
where I have gone I flipped back and
forth so frequently between laughing
because I'm supposed to because the
movies getting it right and laughing
because I don't quite understand what
they're trying to do well it should be
told like the only weight really comes
from when Mark Wahlberg and Denzel
Washington are like bantering but that
can be [ __ ] improv for all we know
yeah reasons that the sea number three
weird dialogue CIA the CIA the CIA that
one [ __ ] see it was like so the CIA is
it on this yet CIA the CIA yes the sea I
am sometimes in the same scene it was
like did someone like right for one
character the other one wrote for
another charity they just like way whoa
were this Joe come for go ahead of know
her from this guy and sometimes the
dialogue was just so like simple but see
the problem with this is that specific
zine is that that didn't feel like a
joke to me it felt like somebody wrote
that exchange between those characters
and didn't intend it to be funny because
you could make that work in a funny way
but it's like it felt like someone took
a break to go the audience need to
understand this can you say it a few
more times yeah sometimes it's like
super expositional and then other times
it's like yeah we're just saying this to
pass the m4
along you know reason enough to see
number four James Marsden I like this
guy never thought you'd be saying that
but not in this [ __ ] memory he here I
think was the worst actor in this film
James Morrison was he supposed to be
like you know of one of the villains
never casting as a villain again you
just cannot pull this off or at least
don't do it the way they did it in this
movie because because the problem is
they make him look nerdier than you've
ever seen yeah he's like way skinnier
than Mark Wahlberg in stuff and then
they play him off like like like he's
supposed to be the douchebag frat boy
who's giving you giving you know our
plucky heroes a hard time and then
you're like how did they ever become a
high ranking military officer this is an
annoying douchebag bully you like any
any just he just people laugh sometimes
I lines that he said seriously [ __ ]
reason not to see number five Paula
Patton I've seen her another things I
like her another that I liked her
mission impossible for but she's a
different actress in this movie you
[ __ ] up man you're just uh like you're
working with Denzel and I was like are
you acting for fast & furious 7 what the
hell are you doing exactly again she was
the only character in this movie who
distracted me in the sense that I just
didn't think she gave a good performance
for whatever movie she was trying to be
yeah she's like we're good we let us
down Paula Patton we all had high hopes
for you when we watch this but you see
her tits and that was great she's a very
attractive woman yeah there's one shot
when they cut into the next scene and
she just turns and your tits are there
and that's all you see and that's how
they introduce the next scene but
they're perfectly covered by hair yeah
which the nipple slips out yeah but it
that it was like are you trying to be
pg-13 yeah you have again what are you
trying to do his good nipple reason not
to see number six the actors thought
they were in a different movie now when
we say that we mean that each individual
actor thought they were in a different
movie as we've established before mark
wahlberg denzel washington same movie
else different movies movies not just a
different movie different movies I think
bill paxton vatos gangster squad 2 or
something yeah Bill Paxton comes in at
every scene ES and he is knowing all
over the scenery it's like there are
teeth marks on every print of this film
because how much I'm a Valan yeah I'm a
villain but sort of not yeah I'm a bad
guy that's all I gotta say crooked then
crooked I'm gonna shoot you in the knees
and then you have like edward james
olmos who is playing more of a he could
have been in snitch then you've got
james marsden who's doing is like frat
boy just I'm a dick thing yeah and then
you have a Paula Patton who is in Fast
and Furious 7 like me and then you've
got all these like other supporting cast
it's like the henchmen are right out of
like a 90s action movie sometimes you
just hear like actor say like a line and
you have one like one line in the movie
or old one word and it was like you
picked the worst person to say that one
word yeah yeah but this is one moment
and I think you're going to notice it
worth is this blonde extra his featured
extra walks out of an elevator and it
was so obvious that this extra was
probably picked on set and she felt this
is my chance to show my acting talent
that that actress was also in a
different movie and it was a movie that
she was apparently starring yeah I don't
know nothing nothing is consistent
reason not to see number seven writing
and directing these guys just didn't
know what they were really doing hey
that's it yeah I mean it's kind of for
all two guns I counted hundreds of guns
in this yeah there's only one time there
are two guns that come together on
newzbin you could have called this like
you know two grenades and that would
have worked because I think there are
only like to connect really two
explosions there there while they're for
but yeah there's like hundreds of guns
in this movie and it's mostly stuff
we've talked about already but you know
nothing is consistent some stuff works
but [ __ ] you guys yeah not you guys I
like you guys for watching thank you I'm
talking about the the writing all all 47
writers on this film and all 47
directors that worked on his stuff yeah
I mean it for me is not even a [ __ ] you
it's just like a it's just like Oh what
like there's a lot of unintentional
laughter and a lot of Hong going on yeah
kind of kind of just as much as there is
intentional laughter and as formulaic as
it was it was kind of confusing the
first 30 minutes yes I'm you're using
your leg foot block like why why are
they do why are they doing this you know
but Ryan's consensus mark wahlberg and
Denzel Washington are probably the only
reasons to watch two guns mark wahlberg
and Denzel Washington are probably the
only reasons to watch two guns like the
score is cool but you could just like
download it sooner target was cool but
it doesn't save the movie but the only
thing memorable about it are these two
thank you guys Jerry's consensus you
know what man you're absolutely right
mark wahlberg and Denzel Washington are
the reason to see too good mark wahlberg
denzel washington are the reason to see
two guns they are the only consistent
part of this movie and at the end of it
you're kind of like I would watch these
characters again all right guys it's us
again one second later how you doing
hope you didn't miss this for too long
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and i forgot to say
thank you thank you and tell us what is
your favorite buddy movie of cops buddy
cop movie and once you're done with that
if you want to check out more episodes
of reasons to see why don't you come
over here and click this link when
you're done with that why don't you go
click on this button right here to
follow us on twitter yes i know you want
to we'll tweet you back lose shoutouts
for you oh dang Joe I do it Joe yeah how
you doing Joe Joe I hope that's your
name I want to go back to the comments
remember a tomb okay
and one just click on this link to like
us on Facebook and will like you back
like you we won't like actually do any
button and stuff but will like you I
already like you guys yeah just in
general how do you like me now didn't
this would have been the third mark
wahlberg movie to have that if they had
that song it could have had that it
could have added it could pull it off
all the music that yeah exactly not now
and once they're done with all that and
you want to get updated every time a new
review or video is out subscribe
subscribe to the two guns right your
guns yeah we're the two gun you are we
are the two girls i should have called
this the two gun show yeah got two
tickets to the yeah the two guns yeah i
bought two tickets for two guns and I
didn't give that ticket away to someone
else both tickets were for me really
yeah man I wanted to uh pay those movie
twice because I it's two guns so why two
tickets you're okay I think I have your
credit card you go oh yeah you did he
took my credit card will we yeah we got
that pretzel and popcorn she really put
a lot of work into that pretzel because
she went all the way down the counter
there's a really long counter and I was
like what is going on like like cuz
usually eat popcorn a drink or whatever
it's like you know here you go but she
disappears like form into a debt and I
look down the aisle and she was like you
know sprinkling things on it and
wrapping it up and I was like what a
lame occur she was frying in a pan yeah
it's like we don't make it to the order
and you're only putting lots of TLC into
this but the trailers I have already
long since started
you